yo it's just straight lonely and I'm
kicking [__] with bootleg cab today
bootleg cat podcast
how'd you get that name man [__]
honestly we put the mic in front of you
and and the apple sauce or juice set
that's [__] that's hey man I respect
it but I like that bro but um it's
better than lean right
you can't get addicted to Honest Kids
organic super fruit punch and if you did
you wouldn't have withdrawals if you
stopped drinking it I'd be having Honest
Kids withdrawals I'm not gonna lie
Honest Kids withdrawals yeah that's what
I mean it's good I'm sure it's good
right yes I yeah so your name how do we
get to it uh [__] it's a long story if
I'm summing it up like can we get the
mic uh the closer yeah there we go there
we go there we go so like long story
short
I was in school I was going through some
[__] okay dipping dad and [__] I felt
like that was bad for me what were you
doing
drugs so like that [__] had me feeling
crazy I felt like if I kept doing that I
would destroy myself then before that I
spent a bunch of time by myself so I
just called myself lonely because I
really was by myself I was homeschooled
spent a lot of time in the crib [__] wow
yeah so quite a literal name very
literal yeah
what uh was your drug of choice in
school Xanax designs man yep
was this prior to like the fentanyl
thing being a thing yeah this one drugs
were pure like it was like you know I'm
saying You Miley was Miley museums
I don't do none of that [__] that much
no more because I'm scared of that we
say that much no more I still get high
don't Everybody Get High I mean we I I
eat shrooms and smoke weed I eat from
the smoke weed and that's all I do
that's what I mean I feel like you know
what I have heard though randomly that
there's like some weed that's laced with
fentanyl I don't know where they're
selling that [__] at have you heard that
it's a thing that's terrifying yeah I
smoke one weed though so that won't ever
come out with have you ever had a bad
edible experience I don't like Edibles I
have bad edible experiences every time I
take Edibles them she's making me that's
worse the worst [__] in the world I
don't understand like I have a homie
named James who'll eat like
50 milligrams a night that wait James a
tweaker now he's a wild boy he's but he
says he just does it to go to sleep I'm
like right be [__] hallucinating
puking every night like this stuff the
[__] what's the worst edible
experience you had uh I remember the
first time I took Edibles ain't a lot
first time I was like really smoking
weed and [__] like I was one of them
[__] like we made made me anxious so
like when I first took an edible I felt
like I was gonna die the very first time
I can't like fully remember but I just
remember being so scared I'm like bro
this is my last time right yo that
actually has happened to me many times
that is horrible I've been Edibles three
times and each time I was like you know
what let me try one more time maybe I
just had a bad go at it
way worse than eating shrooms bro what
Trump and you would think like
psychedelics would have a [__] tripping
but that [__] really like therapeutic
how um very therapeutic have you found
any therapy in doing psilocybin 100 I
micro dose often honestly so like that's
just what I'd be on you micro dose right
before the interview yeah exactly yeah
and like on my tour I've been doing that
[__] I've been making music like that uh
shrooms just the first time I did
shrooms when I tripped it was like an
actual learning experience for me so I
kind of use it for that right and then
with the micro dose and I just use it to
keep myself open throughout the day I
think of it as like a limitless build
yeah it's like that so when you would
you uh The Learning Experience you had
when you first tripped what was that
like [__] it was just how I figured out
I haven't do all this [__] I'm doing
right now wow so you feel like you
unlock something you you were 100 like
the first time I did shrooms and acid
it's just like it kind of like I feel
like I tapped into the world more
understood like everything a whole lot
more that [__] worked like overstanding
and understanding though like on the
surface stand up under it did you uh
hallucinate at all no hell no offer acid
on acid I definitely hallucinate I had a
bad trip because I took a double dose
tab my first time so I was like super
tripping that was like the worst [__]
that ever happened to me I feel like I
went through some [__] called like ego
death yeah I don't even talk about that
[__] on here but that was crazy yeah
yeah acid's more um visual 100 you do a
lot of shrooms you just get in your
[__] feelings you start thinking
about life facts certainly gets a little
more vibrant the lights are a little
more trippy but you like really are in
your [__] head definitely it's like I
I call it a super blunt it's like if you
smoke the best weed yeah I like that the
super blunt that's fair
um hey so I found this out about you
which is crazy
your dad is I-20 from dtp yup disturbing
the piece you want to know your dad has
one of the most distinct illest voices
in rap history yeah Pop's crazy show his
voice is so crazy his voice is that deep
in real life too bro it's like damn yeah
I loved I-20 bro yeah I love him too
that's my dad I mean I hope so right
were you like around like Ludacris and
[__] growing up 100 I was like here
Uncle yeah definitely Chris 100 like it
was like times when my pops get mad
cause like as a child like I wouldn't
understand it I'd be calling Ludacris
I'm like [__] this little crazy like
bro it's like my best friend right
she's crazy did you like would you
attribute just being around your dad
to your rap career like you wanting to
pursue that
at first I used to say I didn't but like
growing up and like thinking like how
much that [__] like really like was in
my brain hell yeah like it's pictures of
me on the internet like when I was a kid
like recording I'm like but I'm like in
my dad's studio right so it's like [__]
like that but when I was growing up I
definitely was like [__] rap I'm not on
this and then like over time I kind of
got into it and then now growing up in
it and like having this [__] happened to
me I kind of like understand everything
a lot more with that yeah there was a
guy from I'm from Phoenix Arizona right
yeah and uh we had one guy kind of
really make it nationally for a sec and
it was uh Willie North Pole who was
signed to dtp that's crazy did you ever
hear Willie North Pole I ain't gonna lie
I've never heard of Willie came and went
but I mean he's still having shout out
to William it's my guy good guy but like
he put out one album on dtp and then it
kind of went away but you know shout out
to us yeah
your pops ever give you like [__]
tips on some bars because he's a [__]
real lyrical [__] AOL no first
rapper he tried to like try to kick it
to me like I was on him [__] [__] right
like now it's like he definitely respect
the way I rap He was just that um our
last show on our tour in Atlanta my
passport he definitely spread this [__]
that's super dope what about uh what
about Uncle Luda ain't gonna lie I spoke
to him in a minute but my pops talk to
him all the time like yo what my son's
going crazy right now I don't think you
understand 100 they definitely everybody
from over there love everything I'm
doing and they respect it I feel like
I'm doing good for them I ain't just
being [__] crazy or stupid you know
how did you uh originally link up with
cardi [__] that [__] was just random as
hell
I was sitting at the crib one day and
then like honestly I got a phone call
and it was his army and he took the
phone and it was him wow and then after
that he said he was coming to Atlanta
went to the studio
that was that after that what year was
this this was like probably like two
years ago two years ago yeah this is uh
pretty whole lot of red or this is in
that in the middle of that yeah era yeah
would you consider yourself someone who
was like influenced by cardi prior to
working with him
influenced I guess I would say
definitely I ain't gonna lie I love
cardi like outside of him being you're
my brother but it's like he's as a fan
yeah yeah 100 so I was [__] with that
[__] so when you hit me up I was like
down in brazy but I feel like everybody
[__] with everything like he's the way
he met me was like he was [__] with
my [__] so it's like you know what I'm
saying what do you remember what song it
was he heard that was like yeah it was
oh yeah nice it was just song off my
album called broke his heart broken
hearts it's uh the song's called oh yeah
it sounds pretty fire though I like
performing that
um
which album are you taking die lit or
whole lot of red
it's crazy because you know I had this
conversation
I stand on dial it me too like okay but
whole light red is a very great album
it's not action I'm not saying nothing
like that but my personal favorite yeah
so personally for me dial it was dope
yeah whole lot of red was the one album
in my entire life as a hip-hop fan where
I was just like I'm old wow that's crazy
as [__] like I'm getting old because I'm
like
I mean some of the Beats were crazy yeah
but just some of that [__] I think it
came out like Christmas Eve or something
wild like that or Christmas yeah because
I remember driving to Walgreens was the
only place that was open and I was like
man this is this [__] on and I remember
I hit play on that [__] and I
was like
the [__] is going on all right I'm I'm
gonna say like I don't think you should
judge yourself for being old but what a
whole lot of red is is is for like it's
like I think I I only listened to it
once you should listen to it again you
should 100 listen I felt like I got
enough then maybe what you should do
before you listen to it again is watch
it live and then go listen to it again
I've seen him live so the life of show
is crazy that's the album no the live
shows it's a it's a lot going on but
this rubs in next time listen I'm
thinking that maybe I should listen to
it on on some like some shrooms you feel
me yeah you gotta get into it what up
y'all we gotta stop the interview real
quick tell you about our partners at
mybookie man look it's so much to gamble
on right now we got World Cup soccer we
got bowl games coming up NBA basketball
uh of course NFL man we're getting into
the playoffs in a few weeks well in like
six weeks or something like that uh with
that being said let's win some money all
right go to my bookie right now sign up
with that promo code bootleg and they
will match your deposit up to a thousand
dollars that's free money to gamble with
that's free money what are we talking
about my bookie uh let's talk about the
props you could bet on all kinds of
player props NBA points uh well Giannis
win MVP you can do Futures on the awards
season for the NBA uh so much going on
you could also still bet on the NFL MVP
odds as well there's just so much ways
to get money on my bookie but what's
most important is that they're giving
you free money you sign up at my bookie
right now you use the promo code bootleg
and they will match your first deposit
up to a thousand dollars that's right
free money what are we doing head over
there put in some bets and let's try to
win some [__] money together all
right my bookie use the promo code
bootleg let's get back to the interview
I I think I do have to get into it for
sure you got it like I'm not into it you
gotta like like it's like that's what
I'm saying is forward like music now
personally I would say like if rap
before it was like lyrics and there's
rappers and this is what rappers do it's
more of like like a worldly thing now so
like the Playboy cardi fan lives in
Playboy Cardi's World anything that he
does they will understand a destroy
lonely fan is the same way and so on and
so forth now I think so do you feel like
your guys's fans are different because
Playboy cardi fans we kind of have this
like uh generic like funny like
stereotype of who they are yeah and
they're mostly like little white kids
with dirty forces
um yeah but like do you like obviously
you have fans before you started working
with opium but like 100 million he's got
a hardcore like cult following you
obviously benefit from that like did you
notice like some of the fans getting a
little crazier once you you started
working with him I mean well personally
I had a court following before opium he
just brought the worlds together exactly
and that just created a crazy thing and
then we got my brother here who got his
own following so it's like once we put
all that [__] together it's like it's
the biggest [__] in the world no it's
it's big man what would you uh oh we got
another we got another one
this is this bracket right here this
fire back to back back to back backwards
these gravity stuff I want to grab a
leaf yeah let me ask you a question
well yeah yeah I saw her cutting the
leaf up
so how long have you been smoking gravel
leaves
I go live because it feels like a lot to
like you gotta cut the [__] open it is
but I personally I fly I've been smoking
probably like my whole time smoking it's
weird with that specifically like [__]
might be smoking backwards now that's
the thing we smoke smoke grab them I
just started smoking papers I'm trying
to get into that on some getting older
[__] but I just want to grab it for a
long ass time you just call me all the
spices I feel like smoking papers is
like some kind some old people [__] yeah
like my eyes can't take it no more or
whatever wow sorry dude no sorry
for me it's just a convenience thing
because I can't roll [__] so if I go to
the store they have the cones
and you just grind your weed up you put
it in you just twist it and then you're
[__] Off to the Races for me it's
like I like the whole process breaking
it down breaking down the grapple
rolling it up like that no the gravel
process is wild though because you'll
see someone pull out this giant dinosaur
batwing from a [__] from a bag and
then start cutting [__] pieces
but that's that's why [__] started
smoking it though because like you get a
five pack of Backwoods on like one of
them shits might be able to right you
get the Leaf you can just whatever size
it's efficient yeah literally it's
efficient it's interesting it's
efficient though it's like some DIY arts
and crafts it is it is for sure
um yo well congratulations because uh I
heard you sold out the Palladium
definitely which is a big deal man
because
um really I saw a young thug an MGK
there in 2019 I saw and they that was
their tour together I saw Nipsey
headline there it's our variety headline
that's a big deal man um how is this
tour kind of like
been for you like being the main dude
and doing the size venues you're doing
now it's got to be pretty dope to just
see the the people growing with you yeah
100 is definitely [__] me up I ain't
gonna lie it's been fun as hell but it's
just like like
I did like two tours before this and
they was crazy I did it with my family
so like I was able to learn how to do it
and like doing it myself is like I know
what to do but every night seeing them
[__] be there like my fans I'm like
yeah what the [__] [__] kind of like
crazy right and then it's like they my
fans but they support the whole like
world like opium like right homicide
come out it's crazy like it's just it's
it's like bro we got like a whole like
Community like this [__] weird it's just
fire I don't know my [__] my tour been
the best [__] I ever did in my life no
how would you describe your live show
for anybody who hasn't seen it
it's an experience yeah it's like that
simple are you like [__] crowd
surfing are you [__] hell yeah
jumping in the crowd on the second day
did I just let somebody jump across
yesterday because it was their birthday
yeah I'd be like I'd just be wild
they're doing mosh pits and [__] my
spirits they singing They dancing
there's girls it's a bunch of different
stuff going on you ever get dropped
crowd surfing like Drop nah people don't
drop me it's me everyone's gotten
dropped nah I think uzi's been dropped
before what are we talking about
[__] get dropped you jump in
the wrong part of the crowd some [__]
kid's not ready oh [__] you hit the
floor I feel like but then you get
picked back up
listen I [__] crowd surfed a lot in
my day like at like [__] punk rock
shows and [__]
from the crowd's perspective you always
go find if you're at a rock show and
you're in Arizona
you go to the there's always a crazy
native [__] that's the size of a
mountain shout out to my Native American
brothers and sisters out there they love
metal shows you find the biggest dude
and you're like hey like you gotta get
the big dude to lift you up but when you
just jump unexpectedly from the stage
you [__] might be checking their
text fighting with their girl I ain't
gonna lie I only weigh like 150 a [__]
better catch me you make a drop though
man nah bro don't waste that on me
please but you won't get hurt you'll be
all right actually I take that back
Yelawolf got dropped and he um he
ruptured his spleen in like 2012. so be
careful that's horrible yeah be careful
uh so help me out here you got Lord
tattooed on your throat and then you
have the upside down cross
[Laughter]
how we feeling about Jesus destroy
lonely are we [__] with Jesus or nah
because you know a lot of people think
[__] Cardi's a [__] Satanist I'm
atheist I don't give a [__] about none
of this [__] for the record bro this is
so cool but you have a pretty you have a
pretty cool like Dynamic of like Lord uh
upside down cross like I don't know what
to think
what's your religious stance buddy I'm a
spiritual person yeah in the civiliz
terms I believe that is something that's
helping all of us and that's about it I
don't know who it is but [__] I just
believe in that Lord no that's me I'm
the Lord of this [__] I ruin this
[__] world I always tell people like
I believe in you you feel me more than I
believe in like
whatever the [__] they tell us to
believe it in these books that are man
written and I personally I'm gonna lie
see I ain't you're gonna make me start
talking but I feel I mean this is an
interview so please please talk I got my
own philosophy to how this [__] works so
like I said I'm like Lord this is for me
it's for whatever the [__] else too but
like I got my own
I know how this [__] play out for me so
I feel like um come on man this is the
[__] Insight man I don't know like
very it's just like you in control of
your own life like you know what I'm
saying yeah there's something that helps
you entity whatever because it's right
[__] that happens that you can't never
explain I don't give a [__] what nobody
said but it's like
[__] Works a certain way there's no way
for me to explain it honestly for it to
make sense but [__] Works a certain way
and if you could tap into how that [__]
work and you go with the flow of that in
the sense of your life then everything
will work out for you later so you gotta
tap in by eating mushrooms I guess or
just doing whatever the [__] you want a
lot of people let other people tell you
to like do [__] when you can like
you know what I respect I respect
scientologists on a whole nother level
because it is so batshit crazy and the
fact that they [__] represent that
[__] I see that commercial for that [__]
though you're like if you didn't hear it
from us you haven't heard anything
there's a whole TV channel it's called
the Scientology of course that's it it's
crazy it's a wild thing so the guy who
created Scientology uh L Ron Hubbard
he's the most highly published author of
all time so he's written like a bunch of
non-fiction books from like the 50s 60s
and 70s but then he just decided to
create a religion and now he's got tax
exemption but that's what I'm saying
because I genuinely feel like like
that's what I mean with the philosophy
[__] like music quote fan bases whatever
anything can be religion if you believe
in it so it's like
what the [__] you just said this [__]
just created his own religion and
there's people that follow that [__]
[__] make their own songs
Tom Cruise is as big as one of the
biggest actors in the world people make
their own type of music now everybody
make that type of music like anything
could be a religion yo what up spool
like Kev gotta interrupt the interview
shout out to our good friends at Blue
chew it is cuffing season it's getting
cold as a [__] outside right now and uh
you could definitely use a little extra
um fellas all right Bluetooth will have
your dick harder than goddamn
trigonometry all right so if if you
really really you know trying to get
your dick game right trying to make sure
your performance is at an all-time high
go to Bluetooth right now bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg they're gonna
give you a month supply for free that's
right a whole month for free
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free my
friend Adam Wade could use some
Bluetooth that's for sure there he is so
uh this is what it is man it's got the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable pill form it gets
delivered right to your doorstep in
discrete packaging you don't have to go
to the doctor to get Bluetooth it's all
online all right and you get your first
month for free try it out and then thank
me later bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg plus they just dropped the new
blue chew mint chewable which has the
same active ingredients as Levitra and
that should have you [__] rocked up
and stocked up bud all right so one more
time bluetooth.com
use that promo code bootleg get your
first month for free let's get back to
the interview
anything could be would you ever start
your own just for tax purposes got my
own religion it's called destroy lonely
you should try to apply for the uh the
the tax benefits of that hell yeah
because if you have a religion I need a
church you need a church yeah
you go save a lot of money trust me bro
you're gonna run it up for sure
um break down the title to your album no
stylist yeah just the the it's it's
there's some it's an interesting to read
out loud the first one or the the latest
the plus Ultra no yeah yeah well
everything is maximized
place
be Audrey B no stylist and my cat name
is Orchard so I read your cat Marquette
so you're a cat guy I got cat and dogs
nice what kind of um dogs do you have uh
my dog I don't know why I said dogs but
my dog if you have a dog and a cat yeah
they get along nah but my dog is a
German Shepherd black labrador mix wow I
love German Shepherds and black labs yep
the cat be [__] the dog up though low
key right the cat just stare at the dog
through the window the cat never does
like this they can't touch they the
first time I tried to make them link up
that was bad news oh they ain't [__]
with each other at all it's like some
beef [__] I feel like my dog kind of
like [__] I was here first like all
right right you feel me would you pick
your cat or your dog
zombie apocalypse zombie apocalypse man
honestly and don't hate me I would pick
my cat just because dogs like literally
can defend theyself
fair enough like that [__] gonna be
biting some [__] well do you remember
um in I Am Legend Will Smith had to
crack his German Shepherd's neck at the
end I cried by that that was horrible
very sad that was trash yeah so you
would if you had to save one from
becoming a vampire zombie dog I just met
my dog become a vampire wow what the
[__]
that's hard I respect it that's super
hard but then that fool try to kill you
right after bro what
um bro you're a vampire thank you bro
it explains the upside down cross
exactly some real vampire [__] what's
your favorite vampire movie
um them all right don't judge me I like
Twilight personally but then I like
Queen of the damn Interview with a
Vampire that [__] kind of suspect but I
like that movie too super interview with
vampires got a lot of a lot of a lot of
but it's a good movie that's spicy it's
very spicy it's very sassy it's a good
film though yeah it's a good film you
know Queen of the damn is the one time I
went to a movie in my life and actually
got into a physical altercation wait in
the theater call us pause pause I lied
bro she's a vampire movie with Jamie
Foxx and Snoop Dogg
on Netflix was it bones is it bones
bones
that is the best that's the best move I
don't know what it's called bro oh it's
the newer one right yeah yeah
you know I couldn't I couldn't um bring
myself to press play on that one now you
gotta watch that bro you got you gotta
watch that seat it's been it's been
rough out here for Jamie for a while I
don't remember the last good Jamie Foxx
movie I guess he made one though angle
last one of them like is one of them
shits that's just so like hell it's just
like it's a good bad movie like it's
just a good movie you ever see the Lost
Boys yeah Lost Boys are the last one is
my favorite damn [__] like oh we like
Lost Boys Lost Boys is hard it's all
right it's cool what else is a good
vampire oh there was an air
the one the little Disney movie about
the little boy that's the vampire all
right you know what I'm talking about
Vampire in Brooklyn with Eddie Murphy
was gas that's crazy I've seen that yeah
do you remember that one I know this
[__] guy over here Brian Gaffey
remembers it
all right so we're giving uh 100 Yelp or
uh Rotten Tomatoes review to The Jamie
Foxx Snoop movie I'm gonna watch it
tonight 100 what else are you working on
right now obviously the tour is going on
so are you prepping like are you
recording on the road you got the yeah
yeah I'm recording the bus on the tour
bus in the hotel room I'm working on my
next um that [__] called Lucy kill damn
fan drop project what I'm saying can't
curse but it's like that's what I'm
doing then my next two tours that I got
going on so I'm just moving when you and
uh can work on the joint project right
what is like the difference for you
creatively compared to working on like
your [__]
[__] like who takes the lead or does it
it ain't no lead it's different like
every song is different every song is
[__] different and the difference
between like me working with Ken or
working by myself working for anybody
else is like bro that's my real partner
so it's like bro when I'm working with
this [__] it ain't like we working we
in the studio playing the game smoking
weed what game are you guys playing 2K
Call of Duty fortnite whatever the [__]
bro I've been sleeping at this [__]
house and [__] so I was like it's my
real bro who's better at 2K Ken for sure
he's the best ever I suck a 2K yeah
facts what's your team on 2K I can beat
you with any team any team what I'm
talking about like he's like YouTube
hard but I'm like YouTube Five Call of
Duty though oh
in fact you ever go on Twitch and watch
people play games yeah yeah all the time
I love video games I like music video
games and fashion and movies but I love
video games okay so what's your like all
time top five video game
ever video games ever ever it could be
any console come on Devil May Cry God
damn Grand Theft Auto Max Payne three
okay
um dark game Uncharted all of them fire
PlayStation guy yeah and uh hmm I don't
know what I see in this song
[Music]
so far you got a lot of gas man I'm
gonna say Resident Evil I like Resident
Evils
which which was your favorite Resident
Evil I like two ready to remade three
and four two and three were crazy facts
when I was a little kid I had the first
one that was like my second or third
PlayStation game bro that [__] scared
the [__] out of me is playing that [__]
now it's just like them games you got I
don't know you play that [__] alone at
night that [__] happens [__] up it's
scary but it's a good vibe Metal Gear
Solid it's my [__] better get silent
love that too ain't gonna lie play every
video game ever all of them even like
nerd games anime games whatever I really
do a little video game so you're just a
big gamer yep do you have a twitch
Channel
I had way before I started wrapping
that's what I would go do without like
that because he's getting a bag over
there yeah yeah him and T-Pain are just
[__]
making they're like printing money
playing video games this is hard bro
have you done the thing where you like
uh you pretend what's it called role
playing on GTA no I haven't done it I
don't have it um you gotta like do that
over the computer like a desktop yeah
that seems like too much work I've never
played games on a on a computer I want
to but I don't got the time right now
it's a lot of commitment I just need the
controller
they're pretty serious like if you break
character they shoot you yeah and then
they kick you out yep that's that's like
why would I do that when I have to live
a life in real life yeah yeah that's
fair
um all right so how many dates left on
the tour uh probably like I think still
like a good 20 something [__] so you're
writing the thick of it man yeah this is
like just it's just turning up right now
what's been your favorite city so far I
liked I liked all the dates honestly and
I know tonight about to be crazy but
I've been having fun is my [__] like
how the hell I'm gonna have one favorite
date out my [__] and
stop the interview real quick to tell
you
about to Vegas you see you sat there you
know what I mean shout out to hard D Man
shout out to everybody over there it's
the uh illest dispensary in the world
number one they got the craziest
selection of weed you'll ever go to when
you're in Las Vegas there's only one
place to go that's Hardy and you pull up
you say hey I heard about this place on
the bootleg kept podcast and they're
gonna get you hooked up with some
[__] weed all right so go to Jardin
Las Vegas right now if you're in the
city of uh sin or you're going make sure
you uh you know put it put together a
little hour off to the side to make sure
you go get your nice [__] Harding bag
full of uh just a premium weed all right
and not only that you gotta shoot them a
follow Harding underscore Las Vegas I
want to shout them out though because
Harding smells the best the dispensary
is just it's not only the best
dispensary in the world it's the best
smelling dispensary in the world and
look now the bootleg kit podcast smells
like Jardin because I have the hardeen
signature scent candle you could have
one too you could go to [__] Hardy in
Las Vegas just saying also make sure you
follow them online Harding underscore
Las Vegas that is important you have to
follow them because there's some
[__] accounts out there we
appreciate hard Dean when you're in
Vegas pull up go get you some smoke go
get you some edibles go get you some
[__] carts whatever it is they got it
and they got it at the highest quality
it's the only place I'm smoking from
that's hard in Las Vegas let's get back
to the interview has there been a fan
that was a little unhinged like a crazy
person maybe they got a tattoo or
they're like throwing their [__]
draws up at you or something I had a
dude last night who kept calling my
government name and like from the crowd
yeah and like was like like just saying
stuff at me to like I don't like I don't
lie but he followed me saying some crazy
ass [__] was he what was he saying to
you like Interview with the Vampire type
stuff
was he like yo I'll suck your dick bruh
hey over here
have you ever had to like um no deal
with a crazy fan where they like maybe
cross the line showed up your hotel try
to get on your bus
[__] be chasing our cars bro like
running like full like 25 30 miles per
hour I'm assuming white
let's be crazy really like straight like
World War Z type like [__] I'm coming I
need this picture like hey World War Z
zombies
we just had to talk about this like four
hours ago actually me and my co-host on
my radio show we were saying
there's this zombie virus that got
discovered uh at the bottom of this
river that was like 50 000 years old
right
and I was like well if we had to pick
any type of zombies if they were real
I would hope they'd be like Walking Dead
zombies not where was these zombies
World War Z zombies
ain't gonna lie to a [__] like me
who what zombie I'm taking all this
you're like the LeBron of zombies
zombies is coming and a [__] like me
who played cry zombies all day I'm
winning that [__] up you got it what
and I got real sticks so tell the zombie
come my way that [__] getting put down
well you do live in uh you're in Georgia
yep yeah but that ain't the conversation
I'm just saying it's a lot easier for
you to have real estate I'm speaking
hypothetically like if this was a zombie
apocalypse of course shout out to the
zombie apocalypse man yep
um is there anybody who has tapped in
with you recently just like that you are
a fan of that you just found out was
like [__] with your movement [__]
with your music where there's maybe
someone dm'd you or or you found out
they are listening to your music they're
like you were really kind of yesterday I
was on Instagram I was when I was on
YouTube I was watching Crystal cast was
like I was watching them perform then I
went to uh the lead singer named Alex on
their Instagram she followed me on
Instagram I like oh [__] what the [__]
that really did it for me because like
my whole inspiration right now I've been
Christians and she following me so I'm
like yeah I'm sorry did you say Crooks
and castles Crystal Castles all right
horrible horrible clothing I'm talking
about the band it used to be fire back
in there in the day Crooks and castles
was hard hey way back like 2006 Crooks
and castles was that Christian castles
was like what you got when you couldn't
afford like diamond in obeying no no it
was like the first [__] was Crooks 10
Deep and then Diamond came on 10 Deep I
rather 10 Deep and then what's the one
that had the boundaries the hundreds
yeah the hundreds yeah the hundreds that
[__] was hard Crooks and castles was
like I feel like that was like back in
like that's what you got if you couldn't
get like there was some real like
off-brand ass Street wherever you were
like oh you got that at Ross didn't you
exactly it wasn't Crooks and castles but
it was some [__] there was some [__]
that you were like oh I see oh
yeah where would you say you draw from
uh inspiration wise for your fashion
uh like I don't know just like early
expressing like what the [__] I want to
look like I'd be waking up every day
thinking I'm like a character so I just
be trying to be whatever [__] character
I want to be and like I don't know
I told them that this my band jacket so
um
you got the Bain record
would you uh well first of all I always
talk about what's the best Batman movie
yeah
Dark Knight 100 I agree but I do think
that Robert Pattinson one is like in the
running for like two or three I fell
asleep every time I watched that one
really I can't get through that [__]
it's fire I'm not saying it's bad I
really do actually think I like it but
always fall asleep well you think you
like it but you fall so you obviously
don't like it it's obviously not
catching your [__] attention and or
you smoke too much before you watched it
that'd be the problem for real the
movie's slow and quiet and calm so I
just be like what are your favorite
movies ever
damn if I had to name a couple bro
definitely do some on boy we got like
Halloween Napoleon Dynamite which
Halloween though because there's so many
I mean we watch all of them all of them
because the last one was [__] we just
be watching Halloween ends was god-awful
it was but I I like watching Michael
Myers be Michael Myers song right but
that movie was bad but like that [__] do
you remember the one with Busta Rhymes
in it yeah that was funny yeah they got
that [__] and then they got like all the
off-brand not offering random the Rob
Zombie well you remember the Rob Zombie
Halloween them was different yeah yeah
them was good that's his favorite [__]
he loved Rob Zombie yo I [__] House of
a Thousand Corpses what my
Devil's Rejects one of my favorite
[__] movies ever yeah that last scene
in doubles rejects where the [__]
um what's the [__] uh Leonard Skinner
it's playing free bird and they're
[__] shooting at the top of the car
yeah I would be good that [__] is
amazing that's hard and and you only see
those [__] actors in Rob Zombie's
movies because one of the dudes well
first of all the [__] is his wife yeah
the lovely young lady is his wife the
queen is his wife and then the other
dude died the [__] clown dude's dead
rest in peace and then the other white
dude is just I don't know
but they're only in his movies and
they're [__] Devil's Rejects is the
[__] yeah those movies are [__] [__]
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our family at Odd Socks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
[__] world go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsoxofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [__] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [__] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [__] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board you know what I mean we
get to put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [__]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[__] [__] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [__] ethica or
some [__] ass [__] Nike socks
[__] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview so you got uh Halloween
and Napoleon Dynamite's a classic yeah I
love that then uh what else uh Brad just
been watching hella [__] but if I had to
put it into categories because I can't
really name I like like horror movies
like Thrillers and [__] yeah and like I
don't know if it's not aware movie right
there I like just like normal like I
don't know what to call like white
people what's a white people movie
is Napoleon Dynamite not a white people
movie is that
give me another example I just want to
see how far we can go down this rabbit
of what a white person movie is
Napoleon Dynamite then you got uh like
[__] I don't know this is so random
but like Meet the Fockers and [__] like
this is like white people movies yeah
but anything Ben Stiller Ben Stiller
Will Ferrell that's that's why people
stuff 100 but it's hilarious I mean Will
Ferrell I mean look Adam McCain I'm not
Step Brothers but I'm splitting Have You
Ever Seen The Big Lebowski yeah I'm a
favorite movie ever read this that's my
favorite movie yeah that's just five
That's a classic it's a great movie yeah
great [__] movie uh are anything else
coming down the pipeline obviously after
tour uh you we already know musically
what's coming are you going to be doing
any clothes I'm sure people can go buy
merch definitely doing clothes I got
hella merch coming out I got merch with
Elites right now on my tour and it's
gonna be coming out online soon and I'm
just doing a whole bunch of everything
I'm definitely just
expanding what I do I already do close
and already make music so no just doing
more of that is that combining them
would you guys do
um because you know we always see uh
think of like dream deals then revenge
of the dreamers a few times would there
be a opium
like compilation I understand we talk
about it all the time when I can't
[__] tell you but that's just
definitely happening we're like a
gangster grills or something yeah
gangster girls would be crazy [__] DJ
Drama if I can introduce him Playboy
cardi I don't know if I'm I don't know
if I'm built for that much energy on a
record I'm gonna be honest everybody is
maybe yeah I look I might have to pull
up on the show tonight come on bro I'm
gonna bring a mouth guard you're welcome
yeah bring a mouth guard a helmet
probably some football pads make sure
you take your old man underwear off put
your [__] underwear on because it's
gonna get crazy yeah I'll wear something
wait what'd you say just put put your
[__] piss oh bro okay what are those
pants you know what I'm saying probably
like some good jeans or something I'll
just take some drugs in take some drugs
have a good time you're definitely
welcome to I'll buy some Air Forces
Hey listen I Marsh bruh modesty and
[__] bro listen I don't think you
understand I'm [__] I've I've [__]
gotten laid out and laid people out in
mosh pits in my lifetime so you need to
be out there punching an Autumn little
kid no no see that's the problem is it's
a bunch of [__] 15 year olds and
they're they're [__] know about 15.
just find you a good other what do you
like 40 something
I got sure to lose now punch him in the
face I can't [__] nobody up in a mosh
pit you can bro no I got two I got too
much [__] to lose you're scared don't
let it go viral like yo bootleg Kev
pulley Kev scared of my shot knocked out
a 17 year old dusty white kid's teeth at
a [__] destroy lonely show and uh
he's been sued and he's good then I'm
gonna have to sell your merch for you to
[__] pay off the debt you know I
ain't paying off [__] I'd be sitting at
the [__] show selling merch in the
[__] Booth dude like a [__] shout
out to that guy by the way good gig I'm
telling you you punch out one of them
little kids and I'm like [__] put like a
cab just punch me at the destroy lonely
show I actually believe that dude I feel
like y'all's fans are [__] they're
like they for it bro they want to punch
me in the face yeah let's bleed yeah
thanks like [__] yeah obviously safely
you know what I mean
um cool man we'll look the album uh you
got a lot of music out so go support it
uh new [__] coming
hey that was just crazy yo just go
listen to everything no no there's just
a lot of [__] you got going on to
support there closer concert there's 20
[__] dates left you're gonna go buy a
[__] ticket is how can people pay to
meet you and greet you
hell no but I do no paid meet and greets
nah you just pull up and see me I meet
you you meet me I'm a human being I bet
somebody at Target yesterday really yeah
they were like oh my God what are we
doing there
bad girls nice
it's a good place to buy underwear
you know when you go to Target at like
well
Target before closing versus Walmart
before this is crazy
no because that's the real difference
though Walmart is like yo we gotta get
the [__] up out of here if you go to
Walmart
God forbid they still had them things
open 24 7 because they stopped that but
when they were open 24 7 try to go to a
Walmart at 4am and see what the [__]
going on it's a bunch of wishes you go
there high as [__] jump in the [__]
little scooter and you're just riding
around just [__] people watching 400
[__] pound people with [__]
camouflage shorts and American Flag
t-shirts and I got a [__] 24 pack of
[__] Milwaukee's best they're jacked
up on meth and mount [__] monster at
the same time
they got a [__] Hatchet Man ICP
tattoo on their [__] left leg this is
very specific yo where are you from I'm
from Arizona Arizona yep bro that's the
target I was at yesterday we seen a
couple people like that all right yeah
exactly I know what the [__] you saw
yeah but Target foreclosing not bad
you might get a bitty in there it's not
terrible you go to Walmart Walmart's
[__]
the worst Walmart is scary they make you
pay for those like because you know they
beat everyone's price it's the cheapest
for sure but they make you [__] walk
through a [__] landfill of white
trash to get to that [__]
anyway speaking of landfills and white
trash I love all trash we love all trash
I could say it you know what I mean yep
yeah well look I appreciate you pulling
up man this was fun thank you high five
bro of course high five high five okay
there we go
the trailer was signing off signing off